What if I told you, you could stream an HD
movie while on a flight from LA to London,
uninterrupted, all on one satellite.
One!
Satellite!
That’s insane, I know.
There are over 1,400 active satellites in
orbit.
Right now.
Each one was built for a unique purpose.
ViaSat-2 is one of the largest active geosynchronous
communications satellite currently in space
with the highest internet capacities.
This behemoth weighs in at over fourteen thousand
pounds (6,500kg), stands about 20 feet tall
(6m) and has a wingspan of about 158 feet
(48m); that’s like the wingspan of a 767!
The ViaSat-2 is one of the latest in satellite
communication technology.
It can provide 300 gigabits of service per
second, with about 25mbps download speeds.
That’s enough to stream an ultra HD Netflix
show.
FROM SPACE.
It also helps that it’s geostationary.
It’s always in the same place in the sky,
blanketing a huge swath of the planet with
the glory of internet.
That glory, by the way, extends across North,
Central, and the top of South America the
Caribbean, and across the Atlantic Ocean!
A priority of ViaSat is to provide is to provide
high-speed internet to planes and ships, but
it can also help people get broadband internet
who live too far from good infrastructure.
Right now, a lot of internet-providing satellites
use frequencies inside a range called the
Ku-Band.
Its signal isn’t super susceptible to atmospheric
moisture, which is a plus, but satellites
need a big, heavy antenna to use it— this
increases the cost to launch.
The ViaSat-2 uses newer Ka-band frequencies
which are used by military aircraft for targeting
radar.
The antennas are lighter -- lessening the
cost to launch, but the signal is more susceptible
to atmospheric moisture.
The biggest benefit with this new sat, is
that its ONE SAT covering a hugemungous area!
That means there would be less handoff as
you cross the Atlantic.
With KU-satellites there are lots and you
have to hop from one to the other.
With ViaSat-2, it’s like everyone from Caracas
to Seattle to Paris are on the same network!
ViaSat-2 could change how we communicate in
our global community.
There are 1,399 other satellites up in space
too, and each one has a purpose, and a story.
Do you have a favorite?
For more epic stories of innovation that shaped
our future, check out TheAgeOfAerospace.com.
Since you’re still here, can you do me a
favor and subscribe?
It just takes a click!
And if you want more flying goodness, watch
Amy talk about how big satellites really are.
Some are HUGE.
I don’t think I have to tell you, but the
internet doesn’t come from space.
It’s beamed up there from the ground.
Having only one satellite to beam to?
That might be a big advantage.